[Musique]
on est à quelques jours de maintenant
des vacances de noël et je voulais vous
présenter quelques films qui sont sortis
ou qui vont sortir dans les jours qui
viennent et qui vont vous permettre de
passer de joyeuses fêtes
tout d'abord il ya deux films qui sont
sortis qui sont destinés aux enfants
c'est le grinch et astérix le grinch
c'est naturellement destiné aux jeunes
enfants
la cruche qui essayent de volée noël
donc c'est destiné aux jeunes enfants et
puis naturellement notre fameux astérix
ou là on rentre dans une histoire où le
druide panoramix souhaite on a cassé un
petit peu la main parce qu'il commence à
se faire un petit peu vieux donc voilà
donc ce sont deux très belles histoires
pour les plus jeunes pour noël et puis
dans les sorties qui vont venir et qui
vont je pense aussi marquer les fêtes de
noël vous avez le retour de mary poppins
quelques cinquante ans plus tard vous
avez les nouvelles aventures de la
célèbre nourrice qui va ravir les plus
jeunes mais aussi les un petit peu les
plus nostalgiques
vous avez aussi un nouveau dc comics qui
va sortir et vous le voyez derrière moi
aquaman aquaman ça ne sorte de héros
malgré lui qui va essayer de réconcilier
la terre les habitants de la terre les
habitants des océans donc pour ceux qui
veulent un petit peu l'action vous le
retrouverez à partir la semaine du 19
décembre à la fiche
et puis un beau conte aussi de noël là
aussi pour les plus jeunes c'est mia et
le lion blanc
c'est un beau conte de noël où c'est
l'histoire d'une petite fille est qui va
suivre l'évolution d'un lionceau donc là
aussi c'est un très beau conte je vous
encourage à le découvrir pour les
vacances de noël
et puis pour ceux qui le 1er janvier
après quelques fêtes où quelques petites
coupes de champagne aurait envie de
venir au cinéma je vous annonce l'avant
première
exceptionnel de qu'est-ce qu'on a encore
fait au bon dieu où vous retrouverez la
fin du gouvernement ils ont de nouvelles
aventures
donc c'est le 1er janvier à 18 heures
une seule séance
n'hésitez pas à réserver dès maintenant
mais quand même vraiment gatiss de
bricoles bon j'ai du mal avec la france
est avec odile on a décidé de
s'installer en israël
ç'a vraiment on par an chez une opinion
en algérie on part abondé à bombay de
quels rapports et baccarat bolide le
pays où les gens se prosterne devant les
vaches c'est la solution nos gendre
n'aime plus la france
on va leur faire aimer la france
décidément vous famille une réserve
toujours de belles surprises
[Musique]